le
le dossier de soir3 les enfants
d'afghanistan comme ceux du liban il
souffre des atrocités de la guerre et
c'est vrai qu'à travers eux on prend
davantage conscience de l'horreur et du
cynisme d'un conflit aujourd'hui on sait
déjà qu'ils seront parmi les premiers à
souffrir si la résistance comme les
rumeurs l'indiqué ce soir attaque
bientôt djalal abad ces mêmes rumeurs
qui annonçaient l'assaut final sur
kaboul le mois dernier il n'a pas eu
lieu
mais pour autant les nuits et les jours
des enfants de kaboul ne sont pas
tranquilles
le reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
j'ai lu jonchaient dominique duchateau
le départ des soviétiques de la capitale
afghane fut un vrai soulagement pour les
habitants des quartiers jouxtant
l'aéroport fini l'appréhension des leurs
qui chutaient en feu sur les maisons
dans ces quartiers pourtant on continue
de maudire les soviétiques qui ne sont
plus là car ce lundi 20 février leur
matériel lévy jamais abandonné ont une
fois de plus gravement brûlé
des [ __ ] c'est soviétique glisse à
notre oreille ici même un soldat afghan
qui n'a pas voulu être filmés ils ont
laissé un peu partout des mines et des
monticules et par deux fusées
éclairantes de l'heure au magnésium et
nos enfants jouent au milieu de tout ça
les habitants de la capitale ne sont pas
épargnés non plus par les roquettes de
la résistance
8 février une fumée noire premiers sur
les lieux juste cette image un petit
cratère au milieu de la chaussée
on nous empêche de filmer leur est
beaucoup plus tragique cette mort de
telle projectiles tombent sporadiquement
sur la capitale ici dans la vieille
ville le 14 février
quatre adolescents fauchés et un
vieillard appartenait à ses gosses
oui oui là les gosses c'est ça 16
février cette fois c'est une pluie de
roquettes qui s'abat sur kaboul l'une
tombe à proximité d'un autobus qui
circulait sur la route dite du périmètre
longeant l'aéroport
le bus ramener une famille qui venait
d'enterrer un petit enfant mort de
maladie les morceaux de métal ont
littéralement déchiquetée le chauffeur
et deux passagers
arras qui salue ce que c'est à
l'occasion de ces attaques à la roquette
que l'on mesure le mieux la fragilité du
régime prosoviétique en place à kaboul
au lieu de maudire la résistance ce
solde a émis des doutes sur la
provenance réelle de ces attaques
même scénario un peu plus loin cette
famille sic
une roquette est tombée dans leurs
jardinets mais heureusement tout le
monde était absent couvert
là aussi personne n'accuse franchement
les batteries de la résistance d'autres
hommes l'armée afghane pur fantasme
jamais les moudjahidine ont publié le
moindre démenti sur ces attaques
il les revendique comme nous l'a
expliqué un responsable du jamiat e
islami infiltré dans l'appareil
gouvernemental et que nous avons réussi
à rencontrer un soir en passant de
l'autre côté du rideau en plein centre
de kaboul
six roquettes sur la ville c'est un
excellent moyen c'était pour maintenir
la pression sur le gouvernement
ces décomptes fonctionne au ralenti
beaucoup d'innocents
non maintenant nous avons des croquis
des plans de la ville croquis saint
tronquet ok là par exemple vous avez des
bâtiments militaires et ici des
habitations civiles et bien aux visées
militaires
nos artilleurs ont de tels relevé mais
j'ai tout de même vu des enfants tués
oui bien sûr ça arrive mais les
moudjahidine avait prévenu la population
si vous ne voulez pas vous faire tuer il
faut quitter kaboul interview exclusive
de ce projet jean pagé le jonchet
moudjahidine infiltrés au gouvernement
la suite des dossiers en compte dans nos
prochaines éditions
sans transition le sport